[Music]
this might be good news to a lot of
people um but apple's ios 16 which is
coming out in september
is going to allow users to edit and
unsend text messages no
that's great news you could edit them
after you sent them already so like have
you said something well can't you do
that now and delete it or not only on
your side it'll be deleted i think so
now i can i can text okay so before they
read it you can alter yeah even after
they read it that's what would it be
changed live it'll it'll look different
it'll look edited so it'll change color
dude can you imagine arguing with your
[ __ ] like love the significant other
and then they're like no you said this
and then you're like did i and then you
changed it already would be i think
instead of blue it would it would be
white okay so you can still tell whether
or not that's editing absolutely okay
because otherwise that gets worse
otherwise
yeah we're entering a whole nother realm
yeah and we're rewriting history you'd
be able to edit them after they've
already been sent so if you said
something and you [ __ ] up or you like
it came out wrong
um like you're in your
oh yeah yeah because that would that's
some to some people let's make or break
make or break it you could lose a whole
relationship
no i meant apostrophe are you yeah you
better fix that god she's stupid
it was good about last year oh it was
fine as you guys um autocorrect have
been doing like weird [ __ ] like instead
of can it just keeps going to cat
or like i can never write [ __ ]
without go ducking i have to go back
that's for everyone right no i don't
know i don't know
do you do that do you do the one one
something
how does it even work everybody does
this i set it up and i try it but
remember t9 oh t9 was great tm is great
because you could text while the phone's
in your pocket and you have to look at
it i didn't have those kinds of skills
but because you know the nine you know
like
i'll do that during competition with
yourself to see how fast you can
spell out the stuff was great dude but
you miss it do you miss having like
buttons to push i miss buttons
i think the height of my enjoyment was
like the sidekick oh yeah i had one of
those it just was like because at that
point they started trying to uh
like experiment with the aesthetically
pleasing like button push physicalities
so they started like making buttons
funner to push and like nicer to feel
and then they just went well that's why
they had like the haptic feedback on the
phone so you still feel like oh
exactly yeah yeah yeah yeah dude the
flip phone was sick though i thought it
was [ __ ] jack bauer for a couple days
you know oh dude yeah with the this
thing yeah that way
yeah
sick oh yeah that was nice yeah he's
walking around really fast too yeah in a
hurry he's like go for bauer dude it's
only got 24 hours yeah every episode
i think we're a lucky generation that we
got to like experience all of these
things up to what we have now that's
true we were a part of it all we
appreciate it more i think yeah i think
it's cool it's like we saw it all unfold
from pagers and i think this is a good
thing that you can uh you can edit your
texts and uh and unsend them yeah for
real incentives that's gonna be war
though but it'll stay on like it does oh
it will will it i don't know
i don't know because what if you go back
and then you're just like i never said
those things mostly well you technically
didn't a plethora of onset oh you have
15 minutes
you can unsend it completely within the
50 minute window and it'll it won't like
it never happened what if i write
something now and then my brother writes
i agree and then i edit it to like i
want to [ __ ] mom yeah and then it's like
how you [ __ ] want to [ __ ] mom
[Laughter]
but then but then he edits his back and
then i'm deleting my text it's like [ __ ]
it's gonna be wars i cannot stop i'll
never get to sleep every 15 minutes i
want to [ __ ] with that 50 minute window
damn can you grab anthony's phone
have you ever sent texts and you wish
that you did it and you
wanted to unscent absolutely i always
have a fear that i'm gonna send um
someone like outside of this jk realm
professionally
nudes
yeah
so
are you know what is it messages or is
also
photos videos you can also what kind of
nudes how do you take your nudes uh i
think for men there's very little
choices yeah so what's your style i've
done uh put a tripod this
is your is your dick out is it yours
i get i get i get self-conscious about
leaving my face in there because i'm
like i don't want to be known on the
internet but then if i really really you
know well they did like that
you gotta cover your tattoos too no but
but then if i want to show them look
i trust you here's my face
but also here's my you're being
vulnerable yeah
you know i do it i do the whole thing
or like there's like there's like this
position the guard position oh yeah yeah
i'm trying to be unique because i'm a
creative what do i feel like that was
your story that you told the past that
you like were cybering with or like
you were like having any face time sex
with someone
and you're like in the shower or some
[ __ ] like that he was here well
which one are you talking a lot of cyber
sex in here man no i took a no i i know
which one you're talking about okay i
was in a conversation and we were just
facetiming each other and i just go
shower she goes okay whatever that's the
one and then and then i set the phone up
like this it was in a hotel you know how
they had the [ __ ] glass like mugs and
[ __ ] and i just and i just held it in
there and it actually putting a phone in
a cup is really good because it
amplifies the sound and it and it stands
up like it was perfect yeah i was like
that wow so then i was having a
conversation with her and i was
showering and then
i heard moans and i said are you playing
yourself she goes yeah and i'm like
wow yeah yeah and i felt like i felt
like the coolest dude
really
it's like that's a real woman right
there which body part do you want more
no because oh my god
well because one you're gonna ask you're
gonna ask what the one i always thought
women weren't that visual are women that
visual i didn't think so yeah nice
you're asking a visual person though i
know you're a visual artist right yeah
artist yes and that was the first time i
was like
oh i'm like a stripper like let me
[ __ ] get off bro and i was like
[ __ ] scrubbing and [ __ ] and i was
like does this turn you on
like less is more
[Laughter]
yeah do you direct him a little bit more
like what would you tell him to do can
you direct the seduction scene yeah yeah
sure that's nice is that good you like
that do you like the shark face
what else do you like okay let me see a
little skin let me see a little belly
i'm just so shocked i can't even direct
no you have to look at this no you gotta
go off the rails yeah that's exactly
what's not much things i'm like do you
like butt do you like what right now
it's on a careful track yeah
do you like butts dude do you like what
you're tame
there's not much moves that guys can do
that's what i realized men are very
limited right because you can do the
strokey and the lookie right but then
like
do girls like watching dudes strong
girls can pick up coins from the ground
do girls like watching guys stroke
because i couldn't imagine a world where
a girl would like that at one point
you're just kind of like okay what are
we doing here this is the quietest the
room has ever been interesting we're all
leaned in we're waiting for you
does it turn you on to when a guy's
sucking his own dick
um i think that's highly impressive
so how could you get kudos
you
correct me if i'm wrong there's a story
somebody like removed a rib so he could
it's true it was prince that was a
marilyn manson myth
he recently came out actually kind of
upset about that because he said that
was slander because he said i didn't
need to remove the rib he could suck his
hand
like why did he why did it take him 25
years to come out about it
since i was like [ __ ] nine years old
he was too busy about all the the the
the you know the sexual assault stuff
but why did we talk about this i'll say
this like women we don't look at your
dick pictures and go oh my god yeah
that's what i think too
just mad like now i've been told lies
yeah no [ __ ] way right it's not like
it's like i immediately like delete okay
you're not like instantly coming
immediately you're not puddling all over
the [ __ ] place immediately no yeah i
know this is just like what about like
what if i use a ring light what happens
then that's why that's why i didn't
think women would be so so visual
at all you know you're right i can
understand that it's not present
so women
don't at least like show their friends
and go look at this [ __ ] idiot so is
it the mystery is is the dick print more
superior than the actual photo i don't
know i think women are oh i think women
get more turned on through their brain
first
and men are more visual so like
so like you hear like how women
typically
have to have an orgasm through their
mind first and then their body so if
they're not present
and then that is true no way i'm gonna
crack that and then also women produce
more oxytocin than men do like far more
oxytocin which is like the love hormone
i could produce some oxytocin
i haven't seen how much
i paid extra for that this was all
estrogen right here i'm mostly oxytocin
yeah
i understand that okay yeah why are we
talking about something like this what
we were talking about texts and um oh oh
yeah yeah and then oh yes
iphone
update too yeah so what you would do
with the update we were trying to push
the batteries of what you can
unscent yeah that's exactly that's the
headline so i yeah intimate photos okay
i made it up i brought it up i'm sorry i
made it
right here okay patenting ideas now my
fear is that one day i'm chatting with
my mom right and i'm like
you gotta see the [ __ ] size of this
baguette this [ __ ] was [ __ ] massive
at the bakery dude right and then like
maybe i'm like holding the baguette like
a dick or some [ __ ] it's funny but i
picked the wrong picture and it's an
actual me holding my dick it's actually
like this
because i'm first glance yeah cause it's
just party size and i send it to my mom
and i'm like oh even though she saw it
when i was a kid it's just not right
right now you know so right now this is
good news for you ios 16 will let you
unsend
what you believe was a baguette photo
what if you have two minutes to go and
you're like how do i unsend it this
works when you send the wrong message to
the wrong person by accident oh yeah oh
this is like the the perfect scenario
for that you're like [ __ ] i wish i could
understand that i hate doing but you
don't like the wrong i'm saying sorry
wrong number is haha it's funny right i
guess because
unless the message is like talking [ __ ]
about said person that's a sad person
that's bad yeah that's not good then i
think you deserve that right i think so
too
yeah it's gonna happen to me as soon as
i leave today
i think i just did that bart would be
able to finally fix that old [ __ ] that
happens to you all the time because he's
always texting you mistakenly he won't
know he won't know until i respond
that's the problem he's always talking
to the other nick thinking that it's
this nick yeah but once i get another
bart in my phone he's [ __ ] yeah i'm
gonna get him back so hard
oh what's the other
burner bark it's okay interchangeable
another thing i'd be good for is um when
somebody is asking you
like if you want to go do this social
thing that you really don't want to do
and at first you kind of said yes and
you're like
i thought you were going to say like you
wish you could unsend their message like
that
is ios 17.
and it's like actually you never sent it
to me never got it it couldn't go what
an invitation oh another thing you can
do so those are it's three features that
are being added they're the most
requested ones the the uh the unsend
the uh edit and then also the remain as
unread
so even if you did read it you can say
you didn't so that way that's an update
that's [ __ ] tricky
so did i but apparently now you can
actually look at it and then act like
you didn't if your red receipts are on
yeah so now there's just no integrity
but then what's the point of even having
a receipt option yeah just take it off
let's be adults yeah come on it's
basically like what they're saying the
reason is is that sometimes you want to
read something but you are not ready to
respond
so you don't want to offend them and
make them think you just turn off your
red receipts you [ __ ] jerk that
sensitive just stop being a little [ __ ]
about it yeah yeah yeah what's with that
too it's like it's like you love me
right it's like dude i read it last
night 12 o'clock i'm [ __ ] i was
driving home yeah i'll text you in the
morning [ __ ] god i saw this meme today
and then it was a meme about a girl that
was like girl i don't know why he he's
not responding to me it says that he's
on his phone right now and then she's
like have you seen how men use the phone
they'll watch a lawnmower trying to go
off in the in the bottom of the sea for
two hours
yeah sidetracked that's actually very
true yeah yeah i mean
she doesn't we played smash brothers so
[ __ ] long that i've had so many
unreads and people wanna talk about
unreads nick done read that number
fifteen hundred
fifteen hundred on reds texas yeah i
don't [ __ ] i only have a hundred
fifteen hundred fifteen are any of these
important they're all dick pictures
what do you think what do you think what
do you think what do you think
the thing is i don't even know how to
check my text messages
nobody's showing me
you are really telling the truth because
this dude was like hey i was like hey
did you see the thing i posted on jk
news instagram and he goes how do you
see that
but he could do everything on crypto
though yeah how could you be so
technologically like stunted but at the
same time you could be i love one thing
and i hate the other i agree what do you
think you're selectively savvy
selectively selectively savvy that's
what my wife says about me and i really
enjoy that
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you